each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay welcome everybody to the session of
the Microsoft II science workshop and
this is our session which I gave the
name to which is advances in software
support many of the other sessions in
the workshop concern how we use
computing in E science and this one is
perhaps the one which is particularly
different and comes from the bottom and
how do we support all of these wonderful
advanced wonderful application packages
which the other sessions are all hearing
about so we've got two papers here today
and the first one is going to be given
by sugiere to be from the University of
Maryland very not too far from here down
south and he is a research professor
there and his paper is entitled software
support for hybrid computing over to you
yep
pointer
tapa yeah okay thanks
good morning today I will talk about the
software support in hyper computing and
the name I want to clear right here is
the hybrid community here means how we
connect that conventional computer
consists of like IBM's Power PC or maybe
Intel Oh AMD with a celebrated like IBM
style and GPU and we will talk about
what kind of software can be used for
this kind of application II i will first
talk about the background behind this
then they will talk about the hybrid
computing architecture in particular i
will talk about the GPU and IBM self
because that's two is the popular one
used in the salary as a celebrator let
me talk about three software apparently
can be used for this hyper computing
architecture and the first one is from
my vm the second one is really widely
used in high-profile meeting a community
and sir one is coming from the business
section but we apply to high-performing
computing and i give you a summary i
want to mention the software i'm talking
about here I'm not really talk about
real low-level programming like a socket
and all this repackage edge web based on
socket the background here it is we see
the train is the microprocessor degree
from the single single very powerful
processor to multi-core and you can see
CPU hair like 26 even a right now in the
inhale like something like that in a
helium and a few years ago IBM cell come
out actually so here is the sony
playstation number three but they have
ESP you later on you have david inhale
make their traditional GPU convert into
the general-purpose GPU now you have
like a 1100 more swimming processor so
really have a lot of processor is a
palace tiny processor but that can be
used for general purpose theta parallel
so it's really for this conference we
talk about data intensive and the GPU
also IBM cell actually can be good for
this area ok the question really is how
can we utilize this powerful computing
to do some application so what I want to
use this diagram to show the current
computer system consists of of the
cellar eater this is where the people
doing the so-called data in 10 say or
compute intensive calculation is that
cluster consists of auto say inhale
plate but now you have some new
accelerator come out like a David in GPU
and this is a the GPU and you can plug
in as a one of the graphic car and now
you saw at IBM nah sell blade this
dietary from the same parts are used in
please priest history but for if you
want to connect the GPU to the cluster
you have to have something like a cpu to
connect the TPU into the cluster and for
example like in the hidden internally
helium this lit is a cell in he'll play
for the IBM you can reconnect to the
cluster but the point from the manual
question here is you have this kind of
hardware and it's like a commanding
hardware how can you connect to the
cluster ok your decision you want to
utilize this hybrid system to do some
application for example like climate and
I think right now climbing you're
circling live at the interesting because
the global change or global warming for
example if you do the global warming's
investigation you have to understand how
the energy come in from you know son now
how they be absorbed by the cloud and
refract back from Earth and you had to
understand this kind of physical
modeling and this kind of I modding is
perfect good for utilize the GPU to a
salary and this the whole thing we want
to do for the hybrid
UD give you a very quick brief we're on
the climate model because the other
thing with target so if you do climate
model or even whether part depending how
much a physical thing you want to model
you really give all other component but
some part is very not compute int n0
data-intensive but some part it is to
worry compute-intensive the one we pick
out today here is for demonstration is
the sole early solar religion because
this is the ultimate the energy source
for all the climate change so this
really NASA production code to do the
climate or maybe because the near term
weather forecasting because if there's
louder component inside a model the the
model can be like say 100 saldana code
but if you do the providing you found
out only a few component can be data
intensive or maybe compute-intensive the
one we talked about here is it a one
solution and this very very compute
intensive and if you really break down
the profiling other performance on the
dynamics part which really calculate how
the air circulate around Earth can be
probably say twenty-five percent but
radiation part in total can be another
twenty or twenty-five percent so if you
really can spit out the solution you can
really contribute whole calculation you
know reduce Oh a computing time so if
you do the climate modeling basically
the weighted is the same thing for to
the data can be composing it a date
accommodation fall for the same with
deal with so-called a physical modeling
basically is how do you model data you
know in one column okay so two years ago
we start a project try to see how can we
utilize IBM sell the riddle use IBM cell
here is at that time if even use Intel
Core say the peak performance a maybe
they think thinking okay but I thought
I'm IBM cell can be like 200 so
immediate had a 10 X 4 from him
improvement
that's really the reason behind people
want your salary because you can like
that that like a factor 10 also
performance improvement okay so we did
this kind of Investigation what we did
here it really is we decompose the model
into the gray then then we also
decompose data along vertical direction
so if you want to utilize the IBM cell
for example you have to really figure
out how to map your data into the
smaller memory inside each smaller core
and this only have 20 56k but for
regular Intel people normally use one
gig so that's really the problem if you
want to use any salary like GPU or cell
you have to really pay attention how can
you do utility composition from
traditional like Intel like one gig to
gig memory into the salary that which
how many we have se fue que in this case
maybe 200 k that's really the challenge
we did the porting and explain some time
to the cell coding we actually got very
good performance and you can see the
green bar is the one we use cell okay
and this year one for tommo is from at
that time the latest Intel Core ok if
you look at the Intel process
performance in the video core is now
really improved the performance a lot
it's still likes a 10k prob maybe 20
gift wrap but they add a lot of poor ok
so here we can get like like a
probability 10x improvement use one IBM
cell processor against one intel core ok
I think that's really make people happy
because if you can do some kind of
physical modeling if you can accelerate
certain part of component basically
scientists can Adam all completa cut
complexity into the modeling so you can
really even get more science out of this
ok then we do this we think oh this is
really nice but how can we connect to
you know the major computing platform
because if you run
the big calculation right if you talk
about a teraflop data or maybe perfect
data you cannot use your single machine
on your desk you hell you ignore
something like Craster okay another
question is how can you connect the
salary like IBM sell to the cluster and
this really the fundamental problem very
few people hide pot I know other people
to the investigation and GPU or cell but
that's only doing the investigation on
desktop how can connect the seller
either to the min cluster I think that's
do the open question so now the tpo
getting more popular because earlier GPU
even my Mac had TV you but if you look
at the GPU programming they pay more
attention to fast computing really how
do you connect the GPU to your CPU but
it did not say anything but you know how
you connect your GPU to you know the
cluster because that's not their major
market so if you look at a GPU
programming you can do the tpo coding
with Sadie reading CUDA but now you have
industrial standard that's probably gave
you something to student hope you can do
something in standard way and you have
opencl come out but if you want to
connect the GPU to cpu you have user
CUDA Omega opencl but the question still
remain how can we connect the GPU back
to the cluster but internally you have
still using hosting CP you ok for GPU
computing just like a cell computing
basically you're still need divided data
is data also competing between the CPU
and GPU you want to make sure the data
in 10 say or compute intensive on the
GPU and the management on cpu if you
want to connect your GPU into the
cluster you had to make cpu to connect
to other GPU I just don't try to make
comparison for GPU and the CP of the nsl
is it's very similar so that's why I
think what we talked about here really
kind of private GPU also the cell but I
emphasize ourselves today basically the
CPU in
case of cell is really croissant into
the main CPU in a Cell it's like a PPE
okay but for the GPU you have like tiny
individual streaming processor that's
Christ funding to the cell in the video
spe so it's to sing really match each
other the difference here is IBM cell
they pack everything in one chip if you
do GPU and you have yours PCI Express
car to connect this thing this can be
much much slow and that's a difference
so we look into what kind of software as
you can be used to connect you know you
accelerated like GPU or cell into the
main frame computer so we found out the
IBM I should have some package as a part
of self-programming package they try to
facility coding because circling inside
unit is level lower level even compared
to traditional I people use the MPA so
if you try to connect you sell to the
cluster that's even harder so that's why
IBM developed this package try to
cheddars ease the programming to connect
yourself like a salary that poo on to
the mainframe computer but will be found
here this quite surprised I mean this
package helping release 41 years also
but if you look at a wipe it's only few
people using but it is really inside a
lot of some house project like go run a
project because Road Runner is the one
utilized IBM cell and AMD you know this
really hyper system and it's the first
one brick the one path from performance
but this software somehow is not work
whether they use so we will not talk
about this a lot so now we look at into
MPI I'm here is the one the people use
in high-performing computing so if you
use cluster if you want to scare the
scalability portable most people use NPI
so ampia is really also flexible that's
another way to
think about mvi but it's not easy the
program so the program is critical the
problem related to if you want to
connect your salary to use mpa this is
the video problem you have to really
split the existing application there's
some kind of application specific
communication mechanism mechanism you
have to split up communicator so you can
really link this a salary to back to
cluster that's really the problem if you
had koleksi you know producting code you
have certain complicated way to do the
communication and that's can be the
problem another thing here is you have
to have the MPA installation on both
sides unser salary there and also on the
hosting computer and that's also the
problem if you like the if you want to
connect IBM cell which is powerpc
architecture connect to an Intel cluster
which is x86 you how to deal with a
different operating system and also the
little Indian and beginning the
conversion stuff I think that's a really
problem but openmpi doing this but it's
only mph openmp support it so there's
certain limitation how you use I'm here
to do this kind of application support
but we take this kind of thing with
Morris for demonstration so what we did
here really is we try to do some kind of
a salary certain say like particle
calculation that's almost like a data
streaming stuff and you can do that
basically use MPI to set up you know the
this a cell play and this is just
powerpc play so MPs very factual you can
use mpa and tools to set up this
configuration you have em played on the
south side and also in played in the
PowerPC side this very frightful
configuration but I see also need to
remember when you do this hybrid
computing you had like two different
executable because on this side you had
to use a salary specific API to do some
coding but this one probably do
traditional coding so you have to have
to executable to untie pinner
architecture that's what the saying you
have to reconsider we do
musician to weekend to the calculation
here then pass over to powerpc that's
like a management then finally we can go
to the hyper work we do this
successfully and we can see this
accurate real-time calculation so we can
see me to say one meeting particle in
the cell plate then go through the
powerpc then transfer to the hyper world
so this is real-time streaming so we can
do that yes I'm here then later on we
found out maybe you can using something
the map either because mph good
airbaltic gris mpa is the low
programming prayer that param other side
you have problem to waste a different
architecture and also you have problems
say it's only one open source open mpi
to do this kind of thing so if you were
already using intel mpa let's suppose
faster you majoring in the problem so we
try to do something maybe to some
application which may not use mpa so
then we found out the IBM accurately
well another software co dynamics
application virtualization so what they
do basically is originally designed is
try to accelerate microsoft excel in the
basically enough in financial world they
had a lot of data but wanted to a lot of
data analysis you know you can now use a
Microsoft Excel so you had a salary the
way to do that is your front line using
Microsoft Excel then in packet end you
can connect IBM sell to a celebrate so
that's really perfect good case for the
celebration so they have this case but
we user like in hpc application so the
IBM software here I think the good part
is they have were nice user interface so
in this particular case if you have
really just to inhale saw blade we can
communicate using IBM DV to talk to
celebrate ur and the celery talk the DVD
we will responsible to make your
question and attitude in a saturated so
it's really nice way to do this on the
arm the job distribution and this really
the diagram you can get to get a detail
but I want to
sighs here this right one is the one
user code the other thing we pay
attention we don't care about how you do
this kind of interface or translation so
in this particular case if you have the
CC profits code only thing you want to
modify is your pad H file so when you
modify that I style you can create
skeleton nose stop code but that's
already in the software part okay
another part here really is when you set
up this skeleton you can change this a
salaried apart too either sell coding on
media stripers a regular coding without
even touch to sell the client side I
think that's very remarkable so this is
real case we did this so basically we
have the code at a shop before we had a
Code Orange everyone on the inhale so
now we take basically we first use EV to
farm out to the celebrator in the case
we were not using a the as SP you which
is really doing additional celebration
so we got certain performance so
dementia TV is working but later on we
simply simply replace this one with the
one we sell implementation which can be
a lot of speed up we did not touch
anything on the Trans Am I think that's
good because think about the client side
if you had actually climbing the code
which can be maybe 100 100 thousand on
the code you don't want thi this very
open so here we just use same interface
we change your salary here so we can get
a performance gain but without touch the
the client side I think that's really
very good feature for this at software
and this the performance we get so the
first one is the DV building a broker so
if you add more accelerator basically
this brokers contributors who differen
the seller either so you really can skip
up your performance linearly with number
of Hoops processor the salary ok the
second thing here it is
we we see the provement in the legs you
can be like in this particular case we
can get like 17 x improvement okay
that's really really really good you
know for whatever people want to spend
time doing cell coding that's very
rewarding but definitely we see some all
right but this overhead is now relief
from software itself and this is the
thing we talked about even is this
morning people talk about data intensive
but people need to remember when you do
the data intensive computing you have to
move your data from your disk to memory
to cpu and even for this computing as
for this application it's already
compute-intensive which means i don't
need latte that come into my accelerator
let's already have like up to fifty
percent over hype so think about people
doing soho the pad for data-intensive
computing you don't need a pie that
salad or maybe by you know multi-core
processor whoever you may be you need to
pay mode take into the communication
card so so for this we even see this
very computing intense a way or see the
fifty percent all right so the thing
here it is in the future if you want to
do any data intensive computing you have
to really make sure the way to transfer
data efficiently otherwise you're does
that's really important act a little
engineering part people say is a pin pin
number but that's really from software
how do you move the data from the
hosting processor to accelerate it you
have a really pay attention but this
performance definitely coming improve
basically we use IP InfiniBand but if
you really use but the part of infinite
value unless a tcp over infiniband but
if you really real InfiniBand probably
this or i can be videos even more but
that's really not software it's a beta
movement that's causing the performance
overhead so just in summary this video
software people try and it's really nice
but i think that the main purpose for
this software if you want to sell coding
you want the coding little easier inside
the cell coding published nice
it will help you to connect you act if
they say two cells processor but it's
really limited okay but I'm here it's
like a programming paradigm you can use
NPA to do a lot of thing so we can see
maybe I'm here will be whether used but
you know deepening your application you
know if your application is very hard to
break it down probably this not good
choice for you but this I think is
really doing that is really you can do
this using the software for the
application without in MPI which is for
example I can Microsoft Excel you can
settle with this thing another thing is
even for mpa in a high-performing
competing part this software also very
useful for this thank you